all next week for the second year in a
row as part of the New York Comedy
Festival we're taking our show on the
road to New York City very happy about
that that's right once again we'll be
doing shows at the historic Apollo
Theater in Harlem
from November 6 through tonight we have
great guests lined up including Stephen
Colbert keegan-michael key
the cast of daddy some to Will Ferrell
Mark Wahlberg John little
now Gibson plus a very special surprise
guest that will be announcing tomorrow
so tune in next week you do not want to
miss those New York shows we'd be a lot
of fun hey hey Conan hey Conan
yeah I'm sorry who said that I did so
were you gonna do shows in New York huh
yes sir that's right yeah I got a
question when you you're in New York
you're gonna do any comedy bits with
like new yorky characters in them maybe
I don't know possibly that's great my
name is Carmine demuccio and I'm a
professional actor hey hey carmine and
hi to you as well I specialized in
playing New York types so if you need
any New York types for your comedy bits
in New York I'm you guys
great we're gonna we're gonna keep that
in mind
yeah that's great I'm in all the union's
sake
after sag-aftra apps extra said trash
sake yeah I got like I said we'll be
keeping you in mind carmine about wait
there's more
I was recently voted in new york's new
york is active new york iasts actor yeah
you know I know I don't seem super New
York you right now but I really cranked
up the New York in this when I'm on
camera you want to see my acting rude I
don't think I want to see your acting
real I'm good
that's great rolling hello this is
Carmine nunzio's acting welcome I gotta
run away from this time monster here in
New York my name is bond James Bond
welcome to New York first of all welcome
to New York well this is taking place
right now here second of all I'm gonna
prove beyond a shadow of a freaking
doubt there ain't no way my client did
any of the crap is being used up okay
here in New York motivated welcome to
New York based on the planet I would
pause I don't know mispronounce false a
half but like it's his planet covered in
snow and ice and it's always really cold
the only animals there is like wyalusing
poem poems you get stuck at day you
might have to cut off put a tarp on
choking noises I'm [ __ ] make choking
noises
to specify that on the couch
[Applause]
all right well what do you think you got
any pots for me you know in fact I do
you can play the part of audience
remember being dragged out by security
how's that hey that's great what are my
lines just improvise right
hey security guard welcome to New York
[Applause]
you